jeff bezos often gets a lot of criticism
for quote unquote copying elon musk
with the space company blue origin of
course
the landing of their rockets is
basically identical
and they have many similar developments
but fun fact
blue origin was actually founded
slightly before spacex
and blue origin's goals are quite
different from spacex
so here's how jeff bezos vision is
radically different
from elon musk's vision
before we get started here let's first
establish that it's a no-brainer
that both blue origin and spacex are
working on building fully reusable
rockets
reducing the cost of space travel and
testing large human space vehicles
this is true with every single space
company
as these are the foundations of
establishing reliable
and safe space travel so we'll
concentrate
on how they'll each use this technology
differently as opposed to how the
technologies themselves
are similar in nature with that being
said let's take a look at their first
ventures
ironically their first ventures are
identical
but i promise this is where the
similarities end
both spacex and blue origin have been
working on building
their own satellite internet services
with starlink
and kuiper respectively but this isn't
really a goal
or vision of either company this is more
of a fundraising effort
to actually accomplish their real goals
moreover
there are already several satellite
internet providers
around the globe so this is not an
original idea
from either of them so putting that
aside
the first major goal for spacex is to
reach
and colonize mars while the first major
goal of blue origin
is to reach and colonize the moon spacex
has been working for a couple of years
at this point
on their starship rocket which is
supposed to be able to carry
100 people to mars at a time and
spacex hopes to bring down the per
ticket cost to less than 500 thousand
dollars
meanwhile blue origin has been working
on their lunar landing
the blue moon earlier this year nasa
actually selected blue origin and their
lunar landing to help us get back to the
moon
in 2024 and jeff bezos has stated
it is time to go back to the moon this
time to stay
so after their initial developments and
fundraising efforts with satellite
internet
blue origin is aiming to colonize the
moon while spacex is aiming to colonize
mars
you may be saying big deal they're
colonizing
different terrestrial bodies but it's
still the same idea
and you're right but here's where their
visions branch off
in completely different directions at
this point
elon musk wants to continue colonizing
mars grow more civilization
and even transform the entire planet
while
jeff bezos is concerned with moving
energy manufacturing
and other heavy industries onto
inhabitable planets
here's the thing both jeff bezos and
elon musk
agreed that without space exploration
our civilization
would reach stasis but the reasons they
provide
are not the same elon musk worries that
without space exploration
there will be nothing that will get
humans excited to continue moving
forward one day or another
meanwhile jeff bezos worries that
without space exploration
there will be a plethora of growth
limitations within the earth itself
in other words elon musk is concerned
with psychological restrictions
while jeff bezos is concerned with
logistical restrictions
the thing is we are using more energy
and more resources than
ever before and it's just a matter of
time
until the earth cannot support our
energy needs according to jeff bezos as
well as stanford university
our bodies only need 100 watts of energy
per hour to run
out of which 60 watts go to our brains
so
basically our bodies are as efficient as
100 watt light bulbs of course if you're
doing physically demanding tasks such as
printing or weight lifting
this number will be in the hundreds per
hour
but the energy needed to simply sustain
life is approximately
only 100 watts meanwhile the average
individual
living in a developed country uses up 11
000 watts this includes everything we do
on a daily basis
that requires energy both directly and
indirectly
for instance if you are watching this
video then you are directly consuming
energy
either by using your phone computer tv
etc however just as much of our energy
needs are indirect a lot of tractors had
to be run
many semi trucks had to be driven and
several grocery stores had to be run
for you to have a meal today the same
thing goes for the water you use
and the garbage you throw out you get
that point
americans as well as most of the western
world uses multiples
upon multiples more than what we
actually need
to simply survive the average americans
household energy consumption
can support the lives of over 100 people
and that number is still growing despite
exponential advances in energy
efficiency
this isn't necessarily a bad thing we
have developed various forms of
entertainment
and luxuries that drain a significant
amount of energy
but looking forward as developing
countries start to catch up
we need to produce a lot more energy
even at just a couple of percent of
growth per year
in energy consumption in just a few
hundred years
covering every inch of the earth with
solar cells will not be enough
to meet our societal demands and jeff
bezos
describes that this eventual shortfall
is the real energy crisis
of our society and what we really have
to focus on
if we want to avoid growth restrictions
so what's the solution
well jeff bezos suggests that we use
other planets for energy production
as we can support over a trillion humans
if we take advantage of collecting solar
power
from other planets and the truth is
though going to other planets and
colonizing them is super cool
the earth is by far the best plant in
the solar system
for supporting human life moreover
planets such as venus
and mercury cannot support life without
extreme modifications the atmospheric
pressure on venus
at sea level is 92 times that of the
earth
and the surface temperature of venus is
500 degrees celsius
or 932 degrees fahrenheit thus
instead of colonizing planets with such
extreme conditions for humans
it makes much more sense to use such
plants for energy production
especially when you consider that these
planets receive
much more solar energy than the earth or
any of the other planets
venus for instance receives 40 more
solar energy than the earth
and 240 times that of mars
similarly i'm sure that the bright side
of mercury
can produce a lot more solar energy than
the earth
due to its extremely close proximity to
the sun
so jeff bezos's plan is to basically use
these planets
to power society but he's not just
concerned with energy either
he also wants to off-planet
manufacturing
it's no question that we have a lot of
pollution on the earth
due to manufacturing and sure maybe you
can convert cars to electric
and planes to electric and even rockets
to electric
but what about making the batteries
themselves
battery production puts out anywhere
between 56
and 494 kilograms of co2
for every single kilowatt hour of
battery production
so even if we were to transition to 100
electric producing the battery cells
themselves
would still be quite polluting aside
from this
there are many industries that simply
cannot be run
without pollution such as various
chemical factories
and more importantly agriculture which
we need
thus running a civilization with the
zero pollution
is not anywhere near feasible so we
can't eliminate air pollution altogether
but
we can eliminate it within the earth and
this is precisely what jeff bezos is
suggesting
why don't we just off-planet everything
that pollutes the environment
we can put foxconn and industrial
manufacturers
and battery producers on jupiter and
saturn and
even neptune of course we can't actually
build anything
on the surface of these planets because
they're just gas
so we would just sink to the core but
what about jupiter's 79 moons
saturn's 82 moons and neptune's 14 moons
surely that's plenty of space for all of
our manufacturing needs
ideally by this point all the
manufacturing that we will put here
will be completely automated this way
no one actually has to live in these
terrible places
and we'll simply need some maintenance
here and there
by off-planeting these activities jeff
bezos
claims that for all practical purposes
we'll have
unlimited resources so at the end of the
day
if we take a step back and look at their
overall visions for space
elon musk is basically their little kid
who just wants to go to mars and
colonize mars
because he thinks it's super cool and
exciting and
that's completely fine we do things for
fun and the experience
all the time meanwhile jeff bezos
has more of a business-like perspective
sure
we may be able to call nice mars but the
other planets are either way too hot
or way too cold and we can't even stand
on half of them
since it doesn't make sense to colonize
them why don't we just
exploit them for our own benefit the
closer planets to the sun
can be used for energy production and
the gas giants can be used for
manufacturing
meanwhile we can sit on earth and maybe
eventually mars
and live off the fruits of these other
desolate planets
now that i say it his plan sounds pretty
dark and
nefarious but it's either that or
ruining the earth or completely halting
growth
in the next few hundred years so i guess
it's better than ruining our own planet
or stopping progress i don't know you
guys can be the judge of that
do you guys think jeff bezos plan has
merit comment that down below
also if you guys thought this video
explained the key differences between
their plans well
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one